ist rebecca
und diesen fall wollen wir weiter
analysieren mit unserem achtung
verhandlungen experten christian maxdorf
professor hier in berlin und vor allem
selbst 20 jahre bei der kripo gewesen
show guten abend schön dass sie da sind
und an diesem fall ist ja so viel
speziell und besonders aber am
speziellsten ist vielleicht dass man bei
der polizei offenbar sicher ist wer es
war nämlich der schwager aber der mann
ist trotzdem ich hinter gittern
ermittlerin und ermittler müssen mit
vielerlei dingen arbeiten erstmal mit
der intuition dann mit berufs- und
lebenserfahrung
sie können die zähne zusammen tragen
müssen sie beweise liefern und bei aller
überzeugung und bei all den dingen die
man annehmen und vermuten kann es hat
nicht dazu gereicht zu beweisen zu
belegen dass der schwager hier auch der
täter bei oder in die tat verwickelt war
das kann die polizei nicht mit
sicherheit sagen aber der schwager der
es in den vernehmungen trotzdem nicht
umgekippt wie kann das sein was sagt das
über ihn aus das kann natürlich
verschiedene hintergründe haben denn der
schlager und die unschuldsvermutung gilt
ja nicht der täter war dann zeigt er
einfach dass er auf die wahrheit beharrt
der seine unschuld belegen das ist
richtig wenn er mit der tat in
irgendeiner weise etwas zu tun hat wenn
er täter war so wie es hier auch
angenommen wird dann muss man sagen hat
er auf jeden fall ein wie sie es
formulieren er hat eine gewisse
kriminelle energie und ein gewisses
stehvermögen dann diese situation die
emotional sehr belastend ist auch zu den
täter oder tatverdächtige personen so
durchzustehen hierbei kann man in so
einem polizeiverhör eigentlich gehen
darf der beamte dagegen die wand
schlagen dafür den
wahlweise dich dann glücklicherweise
dafür dass nicht wir haben eine große
errungenschaft unseres rechtsstaates
dass die strafprozessordnung festlegt
was die ermittler mittleren die
staatsanwaltschaft was sie dürfen und
vor allem was sie nicht dürfen und das
darf niemals niemals ohne ausnahme eine
aussage durch folter oder die androhung
durch bedrohung hier in irgendeiner
weise
erpresst werden wir kennen den fall dass
nach der polizeivizepräsidentin köln der
verurteilt worden ist dafür dass er in
einem fall wo es darum ging ein leben
eines jungen eines kindes zu retten mit
dem gedanken gespielt hat jemanden zu
voll daneben gelegen zu drohen dass
allein das dazu gereicht hat dass er
verurteilt wurde ja und das ist so
schwer ist manchmal im konkreten fall
verstehen ist auch gut so dass diese
regelung wir haben hier hinter uns auf
der wand sehen wir sozusagen die
unterschiedlichen dinge nach dem gesucht
wird im fall rebecca eben zum beispiel
der pullover die jacke die fleece decken
diese dinge die so wichtig sind aber ein
anderes ding was an diesem fall speziell
ist uns so wichtig ist ist dieses
überwachungssystem an der autobahnbrücke
ein system von dem damals niemand wusste
dass es da ist dass es überhaupt
existiert und dass eben den schwager
mehrfach eingefangen hat warum ist
dieser beweist diese spur so wichtig
dieses system befand sich nicht
außerhalb der legalität war aber
tatsächlich nicht weit bekannt
wahrscheinlich dann auch dem fahrer des
fahrzeugs also hier vermutlich im
schwager nicht bekannt das ist etwas was
im zusammenhang mit weiteren aspekten
des falles also der möglichen tatzeit
den bewegungs bildern des
tatverdächtigen und anderen aspekten
eine ganz besondere rolle spielt die
frage die es darauf an schloss war ja
warum fährt er in der situation in diese
richtung und warum wird er danach nicht
mehr erfasst also warum gibt es
offensichtlich eine abzweig von der
autobahn abfahren auf den bereich der
landesstraße und das kann der schlüssel
oder damals hat man es ja sogar
angenommen der schlüssel dazu seien den
fall zu klären man hat im nahbereich
dort gesucht aber leider erfolglos hat
zumindest keine leichenfunde machen
können wir hoffen natürlich dass dieser
fall becker reusch eines tages
aufgeklärt wird hermannsdorf an sich
schon mal vielen dank dass sie heute
abend bei uns waren und wir werden uns
bestimmt bei wiedersehen danke
[Musik]